Zolan, my problem is I'm so focused on finding an EMD available for a city.
If it isn't available, I move on. Dude, quit worrying about exact match domains, bro.
The domain doesn't matter. And by the way, I'm not mad. I'm just telling you.
Doesn't matter. Does not matter. This is my format. I do the city. I do
Bentonville Concrete. Second option is Concrete Bentonville.
Third option is Bentonville dash like hyphen concrete dot com.
The next option after that would probably be.
I don't know if you'd have to go pass up, but if you did, I might do. I've done this before
and ranked it Bentonville concrete co dot com. I have a St. George concrete co dot com is ranking
guys. The domain doesn't matter. You don't need the exact match. Okay. We're in local. We're not
ranking sex toys nationally, which would be very difficult. Okay. Because that's highly searched.